The Asahi had many great players,...
...but one of the greatest and most popular was Roy Yamamura.
Roy joined the Asahi as a shortstop when he was just 15.
Small in stature but quick and agile, Roy was a typical Asahi.
To take on the bigger, stronger Caucasian teams,...
...the Asahi had developed their own style of play;
one that relied on defense and speed.
Roy's ability to steal bases, as many as 50 a season,...
...combined with the team's precision bunting and fielding made Asahi unstoppable.
Beginning in 1937, the Asahi won a string of championships; five years in a row.
But in 1941, the winning streak came to an end.
When Canada declared war on Japan,...
...the federal government interned all people of Japanese descent including the Asahi.
After 18 years as a player and three as a manager,...
...Roy and his fellow teammates had to disband.
They never again played together as a team.